now let's talk about what's going on in
the news with this border crisis we got
the story from the daily mail majorcas
admits 30 000 haitian migrants entered
the us as del rio campus finally cleared
homeland security boss doubles previous
figure as he revealed seventeen thousand
four hundred are applying to stay eight
thousand have been deported but two
thousand six hundred are missing now
here's the crazy thing apparently
there's a bunch of chilean and brazilian
ids yeah these guys have yeah so so they
were saying these are refugees like oh
no there's an earthquake in haiti
they're refugees what's happened here so
there are they've already been given
refugee status by another country that's
why they have the ids which is an
interesting you know
i don't know i don't know a lot about
immigration law here uh being an
immigrant myself i did a little research
but uh they are they were already given
refugee status by another country so
that's why they have those uh ids those
are part of their packages to give to be
given that status in those countries but
what
so you do you know the specific details
about why they're coming here uh just
economic migration
i mean so things are economically
they're pretty bad in a lot of places in
south america um a lot of a lot of a lot
of haitians actually stayed in mexico
for example and a lot of them were
giving given the refugee status in
mexico
after trump lost the elections and after
biden came into power
there there was a
massive kind of like a
spike in
chatter chattering conversations and
some of these facebook
facebook groups attached to the migrant
caravan groups that are out there that's
how they communicate
and the main narrative that was pushed
forth is that the doors are open come
now you were saying before the show
there's like massive networks of
facebook groups that are all like
organized just to get people across the
board yeah and it's interesting i mean
they're kind of automated like as soon
as something changes or shifts like that
oh
don't go to tijuana this time go to go
through texas uh don't go to don't go
through california go to texas now
that's modern warfare yeah having a
bunch of network groups automated to
tell people
you know oh hey now like to push a
message that triggers a reaction and
then what happens is you got to think
about fourth and fifth generation of
warfare which you sight very often but
in today's den age you can't sign a
plane with a bomber you can't send a
fighter you're going to spark an actual
hot kinetic war
but you can send disruptive forces you
can you can disrupt local economies you
can spread political ideology or you can
create a migrant crisis which ex
exhausts our resources yeah um
you you see
a script being handed out to these
people as far as what they need to be
what they need to say they you see
um advice to people oh if you can't make
the trip but you have young children
have your children make the trip for you
so you can they later they can later on
claim you and chain migration can can
happen how's chain migration work uh if
i'm uh you know if i get granted
citizenship i can then ask for my
parents to be also be granted um you
know so you can sponsor people
so if you uh uh as a legal citizen right
let's say you know somebody who lives in
the philippines
you could sponsor them and assume i
think it's 10 years of of financial
liability for the individual and it
makes it substantially easier for them
to come not perfectly easy but
substantially easier for them so you get
these kids that will come
the parents will bring their kids once
the kids are old enough they say i
sponsor my parents if if the person who
sponsored accrues any public debt then
the person who sponsored them has to pay
for it so you basically can just
is it easier to sponsor family than
friends yeah yeah it's hard to sponsor
friends and a lot of these kids that you
see on the border that are being
smuggled over i mean they're not they're
not they're not voluntarily taking the
trip you know um
there's a few videos out there i've
actually posted some of those videos on
my instagram account which shows them
that are clearly being i mean uh we had
some medical professionals comment on
there i don't know uh that's on my not
my field but i'm actually experiencing
people under the effects of things like
hypno you know wow what's it called
i've seen people under the effects of
that with the lack of dilation so so why
do you think this weird stuff is
happening where they're giving out
scripts and they're sending out these
mass messages i mean it's it seems to be
like an organized attempt on on on just
moving a bunch of people into this
country that's that's and and when i say
organized attempt
i was in tijuana for the first caravan
when it hit there and it was
clearly organized people are being
transported organizers were being paid
in dollars
the camps were being set up in certain
places and were being completely
supplied and funded by people from
california driving down and giving them
supplies
with this current version of it you see
um
you see people waiting on the other side
of the border for some of these people
as soon as they cross and getting
basically distributed across the country
you see people on the southern border of
mexico as soon as they cross basically
catch them with buses and organizing
their transport on the way up so there's
a logistic there's a whole it's a whole
logistical process that's being
organized by somebody are they bringing
them from south america are they there
waiting to catch them when they enter
mexico i mean they are basically the the
whole advice that they're giving on some
of these social media groups is to amass
or organizing groups
it's safer for them right
um different than it was with the last
honduran kind of mostly honduran migrant
caravan
one of the reasons they avoided going to
through the central part of mexico and
to texas was because most of the members
of this caravan were actually 18th
street gang members
which traditionally have a rivalry with
the 13 mara latrucha people
so that's why they went all the way to
the through through california to avoid
interesting yeah but these guys are
haitians so they don't have that that
problem
well chilean patient they don't have
that problem so that's why they went
through straight straight into into that
uh that spot i mean
any ideas why they're trying to get all
these people to come to the u.s i mean i
know the people on the internet have a
lot of ideas i mean it's a it's a it's
an interesting way of disrupting your
you know
your economies
i mean
if you have you have enemies abroad you
know you have you have people
um sending chemists to show cartel
groups how to make fentanyl in mexico
you know you have uh fentanyl-laced
heroin exploding all across this country
and it's being produced in mexico
and you have a cartel group in mexico
that is a that grew exponentially during
the cobit epidemic and the only reason
it did so was because it had access to
the pacific side seaports
and an open relationship with a supplier
from china so i don't that's what i was
going to ask china seems obvious it's
it's pretty
a lot of people in mexico that observe
these things closely and i and i have a
lot of friends that are still active
it's it sort of it sort of feels more
and more like china planned our downfall
50 years ago and we're like catching it
at the last minute it's too late i it's
i mean for for
for from my experience now looking at
some of these things progressing
you see this uh
use this new cartel down there the car
the
cartel de carisco de nova on the new
generation cartel um
a lot of videos on them on social media
where they have all this military
equipment and they're raising their
rifles and stuff like that um
they are expanding like a different at a
dramatic rate across the country and
people don't realize they can't figure
out how it is possible for these groups
to be expanding
and they're like well i mean they're a
violent group and they have connections
in mexico and mexico they're they have
op they're obviously a proxy group for
somebody externally and then you realize
that on the state state side
these criminal groups are using chinese
banking apps to hide their money to send
back to mexico
so wow and also fentanyl
just just the massive amounts of
fentanyl being brought into mexico and
now being produced in mexico
um people say oh criminal groups in
china are
smuggling it out
there
that's not how china works you know that
there's not a secret chinese criminal
enterprise that doesn't doesn't
talk to the government out there right
you know it's
if it's coming out of china you know
chinese state knows about it you know
yeah
um
legalized weed
brought
fields of
classically planted marijuana fields
turned into poppy fields in mexico whoa
and somebody figured that that so we got
to legalize
opiates now so that the fields will turn
into what like i mean
so the heroin out there is not that
strong not like the afghani stuff
so they
laced it with fentanyl wow so they
legalized weed in mexico and then they
started planting opiates as soon as you
saw the legalization of wheat in
california some of the some of the crops
changed into poppy and this is around
the time of the prescription opinion
epidemic and how it was kind of weighing
down
and they were ready for something else
and that something else was phenomenally
laced heroin and now the new thing is
bogus pain medication laced with
fentanyl so now you're finding weird
pain press pill presses in mexico and
they're manufacturing something that
looks like a but this is killing their
own customers
that is the suspicious part of it yeah
classically cartels didn't react behave
that way seen a law cartel wouldn't
behave that way right but this is a new
breed of
militarized narco insurgency that is
probably a proxy group of somebody
outside of the country china
i don't know that's the opium wars come
on who else would it be they play the
long game and i mean the opium wars
technically ended a hundred and seventy
years ago but i don't think they ever
ended they don't want to get back you
know yeah i heard that with afghanistan
that the taliban shut down the the poppy
field but then as soon as we came back
in we started back up is that true i
don't know if that's true
i i don't have any spirits in the middle
east i do have friends that were out
there and they say that you know that
was part of part of the the actions in
the of the us and afghanistan was to
protect some of those fields wow there's
images of american troops in poppy
fields i imagined that they were real i
don't know
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you